[Music]
oh
free game music hello and welcome back i
wasn't planning to make a video about
this but it seems that many people
are unaware of the extra free games you
can grab during playstation's
play at home initiative 2021 each month
sony will make a game free no strings
attached totally free
no ps plus is needed i repeat ps plus is
not required
to play these games between march and
june this year there will be at least
one game a month for you to download and
play
please leave a like if you'd like me to
remind you again next month
too okay here we go right now the free
game is ratchet and clank on ps4
perfect timing eh as the new game rift
apart
drops in a few months and they like
everyone to sample the story without
spending any money
this version of ratchet and clank is a
platformer made back in 2016
which is a reimagining of the original
game from 2002
it also has the same story as the one in
the movie so it's the game of the movie
of the reimagining of the original game
rolls off the tongue we play as ratchet
a young longbracks mechanic
who longs to join the galactic rangers
his mate clank
is effectively a backpack although this
is a platformer there are a few rpg
light elements like weapon upgrades and
there's a decent amount of shooting here
too
i went back to play it today and i've
gotta say it's better than i remember
and perfect if you plan on playing
ratchet and clank rift apart
later in the year those on ps plus
should note we originally had this game
on playstation plus back in march 2018
so you'd likely have this in your
downloads already
so there you have it sony's play at home
initiative continues in 2021
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time
you